[Music]
hello to all today
nurturing sustainable growth
also means knowing how to rely
on artificial intelligence to
optimize solutions in the service
of operational excellence
improving the experience of
employees and  of customers
and anticipation in the face of major challenges
for air Liquide
it is a constant matter of
ensuring transparency and respect
for ethics the robustness of our
dia solutions with our customers our passions
and in our operations
c  is a multi-sector challenge take,
for example, the large
industry sector that of gas
to liquid production deploys a set of
artificial intelligence solutions
through seven centers two weeks
innovative operations around the world
they respond in real time to
complex issues such as the optimization
of energy production and consumption
or the predictive maintenance
of our production sites these solutions are
will be even more sophisticated
and secure tomorrow we are committed to the
energy transition and the hydrogen sector
here too we will need
increasingly reliable and robust artificial intelligence solutions,
for example for energy management
in a  an environment where
renewables will have a growing place, the
same goes for our
gas distribution sector, the business
working with the optimization of
rounds or the forecasting of customer demand,
or finally for our health sector with
an increasing guarantee of reliability  and
security of the algorithms which allow
the optimization of the management of
chronic patients
to meet these challenges we rely
on the collective this is what explains
our adherence to the ja confidence program
it allows us to work with our
partners in order to better  integrating this
innovation supporting its understanding
and deployment
[Music]